يروي الساحل المهجور لشمال
اليمن
الهياكل الصدئة قصة
الحصار الحربي والدمار
لسنوات حتى الآن أصبح الشمال الذي يسيطر عليه الحوثيون
معزولًا بشكل متزايد
عن العالم الخارجي
الذي سافرناه سراً طوال الليل
بالقارب بعد أن أشاد تقريرنا السابق
بالحكومة.
لمنعنا من الدخول على الطريق المؤدي إلى ميناء الحديدة ،
نشعر بالكارثة الإنسانية المخبأة
من العالم الخارجي على طول الطريق على طول
المئات من شاحنات الإمدادات الغذائية المتوقفة
مع عدم وجود وقود
للتنقل في بلد في قبضة
الجوع
تفسد مواقف حمولتها.  الشمس الحارقة
، ميناء الحديدة هو بوابة الإمداد
لبقية
البلاد ، يجب أن يكون مزدحمًا بالنشاط ،
لكنه اليوم
فارغ بشكل مخيف نتيجة
الحصار السعودي المدعوم من الولايات المتحدة ، كان آخر خزان
في الرصيف هنا في ديسمبر
في صدى  الصمت فجر علينا
نحن على وشك أن نشهد الأثر الرهيب
لهذا الحصار
المرضى اليائسون وأفراد الأسرة الذين
يحاولون جذب انتباه د.  خالد
رئيس مستشفى الحديدة
إذا وقع على هذه الأوراق ، فسيحصلون على بعض
الإعفاء المالي من
علاجاتهم وأدويتهم التي لم يقطعها قبل
أن يتم إيقافه مرارًا
وتكرارًا
منذ بدء حرب اليمن قبل ست سنوات.
لقد أدى حظر الوقود إلى تسريع هذا النزول إلى النسيان ،
هذا هو المستشفى الرئيسي في
محافظة الحديدة ونحن محاطون
بالأطباء والممرضات الذين اندفعوا من على أقدامهم
هذه هي الحديقة هل هذا يوم عادي
هل هذا مشغول طوال
اليوم العادي الذي يريده الدكتور خالد
لإطلاعنا على بعض مرضاه
الحرجين في مركز التغذية العلاجية
، طفلة تبلغ من العمر عشر سنوات
توقف نموها بسبب الجوع لدرجة
أنها لم تعد قادرة على ذلك ، تقول د.خالد إنها تتلقى كل
ساعة
من كل يوم المزيد والمزيد
من حالات سوء التغذية الحاد  هذا
متقدم لأن الآباء
لا يستطيعون إطعام أطفالهم
كما أنهم لا يستطيعون
إحضارهم إلى المستشفى
لعلاجهم كما تقول الأمم المتحدة  الرجال في
ظروف شبيهة بالمجاعة ،
لكنها تقول إن الحديدة لا تعتبر
واحدة منهم لأنها لا تفي
بالمعايير اللازمة لإعلان المجاعة ،
لكن الدكتور خالد يعتقد أن الواقع على
الأرض قد تجاوز توقعات الأمم المتحدة
بأن حظر الوقود السعودي يقضم
أعداد سوء التغذية.  تتصاعد
وفي نفس الوقت
ينفد
الوقود الحيوي الذي يحافظ على
تشغيل
مولداته من هذا المستشفى المزدحم ، مما يعني أن الأطفال مثل مريم التي
يقول الأطباء إن وزنهم في عمر شهرين هو
نفس وزن المولود الجديد.
اليمن دمرته
الحرب الأهلية  التي حرضت جماعة أنصار الله المدعومة من إيران
والمعروفة باسم الحوثيين ضد
الحكومة المعترف بها دوليًا
والتحالف الذي تقوده السعودية المدعوم من الولايات المتحدة ،
نحن في أراضي الحوثيين الذين صنفت الولايات المتحدة بعض مسؤوليهم كإرهابيين
لاستهدافهم المملكة العربية السعودية المجاورة.
حصلنا على مقابلة نادرة مع
مسؤول حوثي بارز
يجب أن نلتقي به في مكان غير معلوم
لأن مساعديه يقولون
عن تهديد الحوثيين.  نطلب
منه الرد على الادعاءات بأنهم
يصعدون هذه الحرب غير صحيح على الإطلاق
المعركة
مستمرة لم تتوقف هل تثق بأمريكا
للمضي قدما في المفاوضات لإحلال
السلام هنا في اليمن
يجب أن تتخذ الثقة قرارات حتى الآن
لم نر  أي قرارات ملموسة
يجري اتخاذها
تحدثت عن تعرضك
كأمة للإرهاب الدولي
ولكن ثلاثة من القادة داخل
حركة أسد الله تم تصنيفهم
من قبلنا كإرهابيين أحد شعاراتك الرئيسية
يتحدث عن الموت لأمريكا
كيف ترى هذا
كدفع بالمفاوضات وإمكانية
السلام في المستقبل
عندما نقول الموت لأمريكا ، فإنهم
يقتلوننا فعليًا بقنابلهم
وصواريخهم وحواجزهم ، فهم يقدمون
الدعم اللوجستي
والاستخباراتي ومشاركتهم الفعلية في
المعركة ، فمن هو أكبر وأكبر.
الذين يقتلوننا هم
الذين يقولون الموت لهم.
أعلنت إدارة بايدن
أنها سحبت دعمها لهم  هجوم السعودية ،
لكنه يأتي بعد ست سنوات طويلة من الحرب
، وبالنسبة للأطفال الذين
يموتون من الجوع ، فإنه لا يزال لم يجلب
السلام
أي سلام أسرع ولا يمكن أن تأتي المساعدة
قريبًا بما يكفي
أكثر من نصف المستشفيات في هذه المنطقة
مهددة ،
هذه واحدة من  يحتاجون إلى
دعم عاجل. مساعدة عاجلة ،
هل يمكنك تخيل ما سيفعله لهذا
المجتمع
إذا تم إغلاق هذا المرفق ، انظر
إلى الفوضى
الموجودة هنا بالفعل وهذا هو
السبب في أنها تعمل
منذ سنوات حتى الآن تحذر الأمم المتحدة من
أن المجاعة على وشك الحدوث
يخبرنا أطباء اليمن في شمال اليمن أن
المجاعة وصلت إلى
مستشفى آخر تشهد موجة تلو الأخرى
من الأطفال
في المنطقة الحمراء من سوء التغذية الحاد
الأمهات الفقيرات
اليائسات لإبقاء أطفالهن على قيد الحياة
يضطررن لاتخاذ
خيارات مروعة
لمجرد الوصول إلى المستشفى توقفت عن
الأكل والشرب.
حتى الماء فقط من أجل علاجه ، يقوم
هؤلاء الأطباء بتتبع
الأرقام التي تتخطى ما تخيلوه يومًا
ما قاله الطبيب
في عام 2020 ، كان
23 من الأطفال دون سن
الخامسة هنا
من المدنيين الذين يعانون من سوء التغذية في عام 2021 ،
ويعتقدون أن هذا العدد سوف
يزيد عن 30 ، ولا شك في
أنه يقول إنهم
هنا في الحجة يعانون من المجاعة
منذ ما يقرب من ثلاث سنوات  أدان مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
استخدام التجويع
كوسيلة من وسائل الحرب
مطالبين بالحصول على الإمدادات
الضرورية لإعداد الطعام
بما في ذلك المياه والوقود
، هنا وفي النزاعات الأخرى التي
لم تحدث بشكل واضح ، ما الذي
توقف العالم أكثر عن
الاهتمام به.  الأمم المتحدة بحاجة إلى ما يقرب من أربعة مليارات
دولار لوقف هذه الأزمة ،
لقد تلقوا أقل من نصف ذلك من
المتبرعين ،
لكن الأرقام أيضًا لا
تعكس المأساة الكاملة ، هذا حسن علي
10 أشهر ويكافح من أجل التنفس ، لقد
دخل المستشفى ستة أيام  منذ
أن استمر في فقدان الوزن حتى مع
الرعاية الحرجة التي يتلقاها
بعد ساعات من مغادرتنا ، توفي حسن علي
طفلًا آخر في اليمن وهو ما يمثل
الكثير
من الأطفال.  في الأطباء هنا يائسون
للعالم أن
يراها ويساعد سي إن إن